Hi. I would just like to respond to some of
the comments that have come back here. Obviously
people agree with what I'm saying. We had
a very good sports session this morning. The
general consensus actually values their own
sport coupled with combined action from industry
and government could make a major difference
here. The values of sport are really, really
important. I think we've established that
and shown that through The Homeless World
Cup. The impact it can make in the lives of
some of those deprived people living in the
most destitute prevent. So very, very much
on the same things, coming back to and see
that general consensus, it almost seems like
a no brainer. So my real point now is, ok
no one seems to know greater. Why aren't we
all coming together right now? Sitting down
and saying ok let's get something together
to do right now.. And if Obama is saying,
we want to pour money into public expenditure,
as a result of getting us out of this situation.
Mind you a significant amount of that would
be spent on sports. Competing countries, building
places to play, not thinking of sport places.
Be very, very creative. I think India is the
answer and coming out the other side will
be a value space against society based on
the values of sport. Hand played, fair played
and you certainly could make a difference
in the world.